très honorable justin trudeau même au
beau milieu de l'été la fébrilité pré
électorale commence à se faire sentir et
candidats libéraux sont réunis pour
préparer la campagne peaufiner la
stratégie vétérans et nouveaux visages
continueront de miser sur la popularité
de leur chef
la prochaine campagne électorale est à
nos portes et je sais pas pour vous mais
moi j'ai vraiment justin trudeau se dit
prête à en découdre avec son adversaire
conservateur ses lignes d'attaqué sont
prêtes numéro crasse for another time
for comparer and the cherry d'oxford
mettre en opposition la croissance à
l'austérité ou encore rappelé le passé
ensher c'est la version rajeunie de
stephen harper alors les jeunes
le problème c'est qu'on est radioshack
est plus conservateur que stephen harper
qui est plus à droite à la veille du
déclenchement les libéraux disent
vouloir mener une campagne positive mais
les critiques sont claires et ce qu'ont
répété partout pays de paul est très
connue au québec
il était très connu au québec ce qui est
une bonne chose parce qu'il a conquis la
coupe et de façon évidente au niveau des
francophones et ça ça sérieux n'est pas
de chez nous l'on n'est pas claire
desgens mono parlons moi messieurs s'est
acoquiné avec monsieur ford et et pose
la même vision qui est essentiellement
celle de l'austérité pour les candidats
qui en seront à une première campagne
électorale fédérale
l'exercice en nette hausse hier
d'apprentissage certains messages dont
visiblement pas encore été assimilés
d'autre part il ya des préoccupations
jusqu'à ce qui s'est passé en ontario le
fait français donc comme une importance
mais on n'en parle pas beaucoup dans la
campagne
à l'aube de la campagne électorale les
libéraux ne s'en prennent qu'une seule
cible c'est justin trudeau et ses
troupes disent ne rien prendre pour
acquis
il semble convaincu que seul e et les
conservateurs sont dans la course pour
former le prochain gouvernement
ici mathieu gaye et radio canada ottawa